[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui arnaud
de la croix pour la franc maçonnerie
dévoilé en bande dessinée d'amiens pour
son nouvel album satan et ève christian
guémy alias c215 célèbre artiste urbain
urbain pour le manuel du pochoir et les
douars dujardin pour son livre sur henri
matisse dont on fête au centre pompidou
le 150e anniversaire de la naissance
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle nos invités
répondent comme toujours en images on
commence par la vôtre elle à edouard du
jardin je sais celle ci tue le fish
oui une affiche un peu ambivalente parce
qu'on est entre la publicité de mode et
la fiche pour une exposition pour ceux
qui ne le savent peut-être pas et du
mythe langue est un grand créateur de
mode des années 80 90 qui a été ce soir
deux chantres du minimalisme subversif
qui est depuis devenu une forme une
sorte d'icône pour les plus jeunes
générations et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est donc saint laurent la marque
qui a fait appel à cette collaboration
avec helmut lang
on est dans le dialogue art contemporain
mode qui quitteraient très prégnant dans
notre société
depuis quelques années mais c'est
intéressant parce que là on n'a pas à
faire un artiste lambda on a affaire un
créateur de mode un ancien créateur de
mode qui a arrêté la mode mais tout de
même qui reste un monde de la mode et ce
qui est intéressant encore plus dans
cette démarche c'est que en fait les
sculptures ont été réalisés à partir des
rebuts enfin en tout cas des déchets
hors des déchets raffiné de la maison
c'est à dire les prototypes les modèles
que l'on ne vend pas et donc en fait on
est aussi dans cette question qui se
pose sur la pollution que créer
l'industrie textile et comment est-ce
qu'on peut donner une deuxième vie à ces
déchets textiles ces déchets de mode
alors une image maintenant de christian
gay me laissait d'ailleurs une oeuvre de
de vous même de ces 215
je vous appelle christian que je vous
appelle ses 215 comme vous voulez
j'avais l'habitude de me faire à pouces
et 215 donc c'est une de vos oeuvres
en fait c'est une oeuvre que j'ai
peintre la veille du confinement et que
j'avais préparé pendant plusieurs jours
auparavant mais moi c'est pour personnel
c'est l'image qui a marqué mon année
parce que on traduit des fois des choses
qu'on ne mesure pas et on a vu s'ouvrir
ce virus arrive et d'asie c'est pour ça
que les modèles de la photographie que
j'ai utilisée pour près cette oeuvre
ce sont deux personnages asiatiques et
j'ai senti que il fallait que je
travaille sur ce thème et quand j'ai vu
les choses arriver jusqu'en italie et je
les peintres la veille du confinement et
depuis j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'on a basculé dans un autre monde en
fait
ou sous une autre forme de prégnance de
avec la va dire le l'hyper focalisation
sanitaires et on y encore puisqu'on est
on est sur le point livre un nouvel
épisode vous à tous
c'est assez sûr c'est pas fini damien
alors c'est l'image que vous avez choisi
je crois qu'elle figure dans votre album
non non non non mais c'est l'image que
j'ai créée pour l'occasion en fait
qu'ils savent enfin que j'ai nommé
l'être humain en devenir et pour
réaliser un désir
pardon pourquoi en devenir
c'est une vision de ce que pourrait être
humain l'être humain du futur si on
extrapole à partir de notre époque
donc les digital autocentré c'est patron
sexuelle ou un transgenre
c'est à la fois un homme et une femme en
fait il s'est fait modifier le corps
pour le plaisir
enfin dans pas par nécessité quoi et ce
serait une forme de transhumanisme
fantaisiste ultime kardashian
ou d'autres n'ait mais là ce serait
l'étape d'après en fait et vous avez de
la crau alors votre image c'est un
dessin me semble-t-il
alors si c'est pas vraiment un dessin
c'est plutôt une sorte de montage à
partir d'objets et c'est le fait d'un
artiste asiatique lui aussi puis ça va
s'appeler il s'appelle tanaka je sais à
peu près rien de lui sinon qu'il est
japonais qu'il officie aujourd'hui et je
trouvais ça à la fois inquiétant et
ludique
une fois à savoir que cette piscine
c'est un masque instinct base comme ce
qu'on voit là qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait et c'est ray rice et
inspiré et les événements contemporains
et bien commençons
[Musique]
arnaud de la croix vous êtes donc
philosophe historien par passion et
scénariste pour l'occasion de cette
bande dessinée la franc maçonnerie
dévoilé avec le dessinateur philippe
bercovici alors évidemment la première
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
même si je sais pour avoir vu votre
livre que c'est compliqué d'y répondre
c'est quelle est l'origine de la
franc-maçonnerie voulait situé en écosse
mais on voit bien qu'il ya des
ramifications
ça peut venir de partout et de toutes
les époques alors là oui c'est une
question très vache parce que on a on
n'a pas encore réussi à y répondre
complètement
j'ai abordé dans l'album les pistes plus
récente est effectivement les pistes et
plus récentes elles viennent elles
proviennent d'un historien écossais qui
s'appelle stevenson et qui travaille sur
les années 16 cents et il a découvert
que c'est en ce sens en écosse que des
gentlemen des gentilhommes se serait
rendu dans des loges dit opérative c'est
à dire des loges de métier de maçon de
métier aurait participé à leur cérémonie
et c'est de là que serait parti le
mouvement mais il ya bien d'autres
influences effectivement il ya un
contexte surtout en contexte très
particulier très tendu très privée qui
est fait de luttes politico religieuse
et qui je pense a des résonances avec
l'actualité c'est ça qui m'a paru
intéressant dans cette problématique
dans cette histoire alors en angleterre
ça se répand assez vite c'est l'école ça
vient ça vient rapidement et on voit
bien au début du xviiie siècle que c'est
vraiment à la mode à il ya toutes les
les
les branchés de l'époque deviennent
deviennent francs-maçons y compris le
prince de galles qui est initié tout à
fait donc très vite on passe de l'ecosse
à l'angleterre voisine et très vite
aussi on va passer de l'angleterre au
continent à la france et puis au nouveau
monde
j'aborde le personnage de benjamin
franklin notamment qui qui va séjourner
en france mais qui est aussi un des
premiers américains aient participé à la
guerre d'indépendance et très vite les
aristocrates veulent connaître et donc
effectivement le grand siècle la
maçonnerie c'est sans doute le 18e
où on y retrouve des aristocrates aussi
bien en angleterre qu'en france on y
trouve aussi les aventuriers parfois peu
recommandables comme casanova ou
d'autres ouais ou joseph balsamo si l'on
s'en tient à alexandre dumas mais on en
reparlera de joseph des belles âmes au
arrêtons-nous sur l'amérique
puisqu'il ya une théorie du complot
dieu sait s'il y en a de nombreuses
autour de la franc-maçonnerie ya une
théorie du complot qui voudrait que ce
soit les francs maçons qui est créé de
toutes pièces les états unis on en veut
pour preuve le billet d'un dollar où il
ya cette pyramide inachevé qui serait le
symbole des francs maçons
alors vous l'aborder dans votre dans
votre bande dessinée qu'en est il
exactement
effectivement dans cet album j'ai tenté
de déchiffrer la réalité historique
derrière les mythes derrière les
légendes mais je parle aussi des mythes
et des légendes et notamment de ce mythe
la quête un mythe qui est bien vivant
aujourd'hui et qui parle de ce billet
alors ce billet comporte effectivement
un certain nombre de symboles et il est
vrai que certains maçons sont à
l'origine de la création la guerre
d'indépendance des états unis je citais
notamment benjamin franklin
c'est un personnage vraiment important
et je lui consacre un chapitre 1 des
dix-huit chapitres de l'album pour
autant l'ensemble des états unis n'est
pas basée sur la franc-maçonnerie même
si certains maçons joue un rôle
indépendant sont parmi les perforateurs
de l'amérique indépendante
donc il faut là je dirais aller dans la
nuance
voilà on ne peut pas me faire un bloc
mais cette théorie du complot n'est pas
non plus complètement dénuée de
fondements
voilà autre théorie du complot qui n'a
pas l'air totalement dénué de comptes de
fondement c'est celle qui concerne les
illuminati alors vous connaissez bien
sujet que leur avait consacré un livre
les illuminati mais en l'occurrence la
théorie du complot voudrait clé les
illuminati de bavière est infiltré la
franc maçonnerie pour gouverner le monde
alors les illuminés de bavière en latin
les illuminati c'est un société secrète
créée en bavière en 1776
déjà là une coïncidence troublante parce
que 10 776 c'est l'année même de la
déclaration d'indépendance des états
unis
donc vous voyez que les complotistes ont
du grain à moudre à ce sujet mais en
réalité il n'y a pas de rapport il ya là
un véritable coincidence par contre ce
qui est avéré c'est que cette société
secrète créée par un professeur de droit
canon dans une université allemande adam
weishaupt va tenter d'infiltrer la
maçonnerie va instrumentaliser la
maçonnerie va utiliser cette société des
secrets pour faire de la politique au
départ n'attendrit n'est pas une société
politique
ça c'était initiatique c'est un club de
discussion qui amène à se rencontrer des
gens venus de tendances religieuses et
politiques très très diversifiée mais
vahid va tenter d'infiltrer de
l'instrumentaliser il lui c'est
quelqu'un qui participe d'un mouvement
qui sont les lumières radical et c'est
le moment qui sera notamment à l'origine
de la révolution française
alors justement là la théorie de la
conspiration concernant la révolution
française
mais c'est déjà à l'époque quasiment 1
en direct et dieu sait si on a beaucoup
de théories de la conspiration pendant
la révolution française mais celle ci se
serait que ce sont les franc maçons qui
aurait était à l'origine de la
révolution française ce serait la
révolution française un complot franc
maçon on le retrouvera d'ailleurs dans
le célèbre roman d'alexandre dumas
joseph balzamo alors qu'en est-il là
aussi exactement d'après vouloir de la
croix voilà la base à mousse un
personnage qui a réellement existé
son surnom c'était cagliostro ces
aventuriers comme casanova ou le comte
de saint germain à l'époque au xviiie
siècle qui parcourt l'europe si l europe
il a joué un rôle très négatif par
rapport à la à la royauté française dans
la sphère du collier pour autant
dumas a romancé la faire il a amplifié
son rôle et c'est un peu ce qui se passe
en général il y à un certain nombre de
francs maçons qui jouent un rôle dans la
maçonnerie dans la révolution française
en particulier mirabeau or mirabaud a
séjourné en prusse et là il a sans doute
été initiés au sein des illuminati fait
partie de ce mouvement des lumières
radical
pour autant on a aussi des maçons qui
sont anti révolutionnaires contre
révolutionnaires en citer deux exemples
c'est notamment xavier de maistre le
l'auteur n'est ce pas des soirées de
saint pétersbourg c'est un des plus
grands théoriciens contre
révolutionnaires ils étaient minces ont
opposé à la révolution et en angleterre
burke auteur d'un ouvrage tout à fait
opposé à la révolution française est
également trop masson et le premier
complotistes sans doute celle abeba
ruelle qui publie symptômes qu'ils vont
faire gros gros succès b stellaire à
l'époque les mémoires pour servir à
l'histoire du jacobinisme
il est exilé à londres et les jésuites
et c'est lui qui balance cette idée
comme quoi les maçons seraient manipulés
dans ce que baru elle appelle les
arrières l'âge parlait fameuse
illuminati et c'est eux qui auraient
provoqué la révolution c'est un
complotiste hippique dans le sens où
effectivement les masses ont joué un
rôle dans la révolution certains maçons
du moins mais pour autant il ya bien
d'autres facteurs qui sont intervenus
notamment des facteurs économiques n'est
ce pas l'état français était quasiment
fine à l'époque faut pas l'oublier
il ya même des facteurs climatiques qui
ont joué certainement à l'époque donc
c'est multifactoriel et le fait même du
complotisme essaie toujours de résumer
les choses à un seul facteur
voilà d'ailleurs puisqu'on retrouve des
maçons à peu près dans tous les camps à
toutes les époques
qu'est ce qui les unit tous c'est quoi
la morale pour vous en haut de la croix
de la franc maçonnerie
quel est le message alors je pense que
c'est important pour comprendre le
pourquoi du comment de faire ce travail
d'historien que j'ai tenté de faire est
de retourner à l'origine des choses et
l'origine des choses c'est un climat je
le disais très clivée très tendue des
gens qui sont en lutte les anglicans des
catholiques des protestants des
calvinistes etc et qui décide un beau
jour de se retrouver autour d'une table
tout part de là et je pense que ça ça
peut toujours avoir une actualité
aujourd'hui et peut-être même plus que
jamais réinstaurer un débat plutôt que
des oppositions purement polémiques
donc je pense que s'il ya une morale à
trouver si tant est qu'il y en a une
elle se situe là et elle explique aussi
qu'ils puissent avoir une forte
opposition
un anti maçonnisme de tout aussi ancien
jeu direct lac la maçonnerie puisqu'il
ya un certain nombre
je dirais deux parties et de gens qui
sont pas du tout partisan du débat qui
sont opposés au débat qui pensent qu'il
existe une seule vérité un dogme unique
et qui voit pas pourquoi en débattrait
des choses et l'anti maçonnisme bien
cela bien souvent ne se passe est un
baromètre par rapport au degré aussi de
démocratie d'un pays que d'admettre de
tolérer ou non l'existence de ces clubs
entre guillemets à l'intérieur d'un pays
voilà une figure éminente de la
résistance à la colonisation de
l'algérie par les françaises c'est
abdelkader il va être initié la franc
maçonnerie 1
c'est un franc maçon et surprenant j'ai
voulu lui consacrer un chapitre
c'est un des 18 personnages que je
présente dans l'album et qui raconte un
petit peu chacun à leur façon une
contribution à l'histoire la maçonnerie
c'est effectivement considéré comme le
père fondateur de l'état algérien
ce qu'un musulman convaincu il a laissé
des écrits spirituels important au plan
de l'islam et en même temps c'est
quelqu'un qui va effectivement être
initiés à la maçonnerie et qui va
considérer que l'ordre maçonnique est
quelque chose d'important pour lui et
ses fils aussi feront partie de la
maçonnerie c'est quelque chose que un
certain nombre d'islamistes ni
aujourd'hui mais les preuves historiques
sont là alors j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi je pense qu'il était fasciné
par cette société qu'on disait
influentes et il faut pas oublier aussi
qu'à l'époque la maçonnerie y compris la
maçonnerie française était croyant n'est
ce pas pour entrer en maçonnerie il
fallait croire en dieu et en
l'immortalité de l'âme
c'est quelque chose qui va disparaître
sur le continent dans une certaine
frange la maçonnerie continental
dans les années 1860 17 mai qui par
contre persiste dans les pays
anglo-saxons et c'est pourquoi la
maçonnerie
continental est aujourd'hui considéré
comme irrégulières par les anglo saxons
et les femmes alors parce qu'on sait que
louise michel a été initié à la franc
maçonnerie en 1904 si je me souviens
bien comment elle commence à stagner les
loges féminines vous le racontez
également effectivement alors là c'est
un sujet très touchy n'est pas très
délicat parce que ça vient très tard la
maçonnerie bien souvent c'est un reflet
de ce qui se passe à l'extérieur de
l'ensemble de la société et donc la
parole donnée aux femmes l'importance
donnée aux femmes va s'installer très
très lentement très progressivement
maçonnerie il faut attendre maria
deraismes à la fin du 19e siècle une
femme extraordinaire qui va d'abord
prendre la parole au sein du grand
orient de france pas du tout en tant que
mason mais comme féministe avant la
lettre n'est ce pas elle et elle milite
en faveur de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes et elle voudra un moment
donné être initiés mason skandal
scandale dans la maçonnerie ns par la
loge qui va l'initier sera exclu du
grand orient de france à l'époque elle
décide à ce moment là de créer son
propre ordre sa propre obédience
maçonnique et c'est le fameux droits
humains qui existent aujourd'hui
quelqu'un ordre international mixte
il faut attendre traita alors les les
rites sataniques de la franc maçonnerie
ça date de la fin du 19e et des
allemands on doit ça ça t'a léo taxil
qui avait écrit les mystères de la franc
maçonnerie
un livre qui va faire énormément de tort
à la franc maçonnerie à la plupart des
des trucs qu'on raconte sur la
franc-maçonnerie viennent de ce livre
totalement ridicule et créative époque
voilà alors léo taxil ça c'est un
personnage très curieuse un espèce de
mystificateur très très étrange n'est ce
pas c'est quelqu'un qui me vient
mystifier son monde un moment donné il
est initié masson et puis il est exclu
de sa loge parce qu'on peut se faire
exclure de norge est notamment il est
exclu sa loge parce qu'il a crié défaut
c'est une sorte d' escroc n'est ce pas
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
exclu il en veut aux maçons
à ce moment là le climat est très tendu
entre les cléricaux et
l'anticléricalisme en france comme en
italie il se dit qu'il ya quelque chose
donc qui il commence à publier des
ouvrages extrêmement violent sujet de
maçonnerie et il part dans des fantasmes
qui parle de riz luciférien et tous les
fantasmes effectivement liés à la
pédophilie au sein de la maçonnerie etc
tout ça va provenir de là il met en
scène une femme qui serait une
spectatrice de l'uci fait un terrible
voilà ces ouvrages ont un succès énorme
il est reçu par le pape n'est ce pas
vous imaginer pour lui c'est la gloire
et il va porter tort à la maçonnerie à
travers ses différents ouvrages mais il
veut aussi porter tort à l'église
catholique parce qu'à un moment donné
et bien certains évêques et notamment en
allemagne les catholiques allemands à
dix mais attendez tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux il n'y a pas de preuves
historiques de ce qu'il annonce et
caetera et il est sommé de s'expliquer
il est sommé de donner des preuves
n'est ce pas et finalement il dit je
vais tout dévoiler et lors d'un congrès
il dévoile tout ça n'est qu'une
mascarade mystification alors là le
scandale est absolue au sein de l'église
catholique
aussi n'est-ce pas puisqu'hier ces
propos ont été validés à un moment donné
à rome donc ils portent préjudice et à
la maçonnerie et à la papauté et le
livre de la jungle
on sait que rudyard kipling n'était pas
franc maçon
on se souvient que l'homme qui voulut tu
crois en ses livres essais romans les
plus fabuleux adapté au cinéma
c'est l'histoire de deux francs maçons
qui partent alain à la conquête de
l'ancien empire d'alexandre le grand
au fin fond de l'indus mais vous vous
parlez surtout du livre de la jungle ce
serait plein d'allusions à la
franc-maçonnerie l'histoire de mowgli
qu'on a souvent vu plus que lui on
l'avait vu dans l'oil disney plus que
ludo rudyard kipling
c'est plein d'allusions alors oui
j'étais surpris très étonné en lisant le
livre de la jungle le texte original
et il vaut vraiment le détour jean grand
admirateur de disney qui lui n'était
peut-être pas maçon mais faisait partie
d'une société convaindre parra
maçonnique aux états unis soit dit entre
parenthèses notamment le fait que mickey
tous ces personnages portent tous des
gants blancs
ça aurait un lien avec ça mais mon
admiration pour 10 ne l'empêché pas
qu'en lisant livre de la jungle on se
rend compte qu'on est dans un univers
sensiblement différent du dessin animé
disney et effectivement il ya pas mal
d'allusions notamment l'enfant sauvage
mowgli il est adopté par les loups il
s'appelle lui-même un louveteau ans le
loustau c'était un surnom qu'on donnait
aux enfants machin voilà il ya tout un
côté initiatique à travers le livre de
la jungle et c'est le cas effectivement
pas mal de fiction créé par le pipeline
vous citiez tout à l'heure frédéric
taddeï le fameux film et le film dont on
parlait donc que l'homme qui voulut être
roi pays les jouets notamment par
michael caine mais aussi par sean
connery sean connery qui lui même est
maçon n'est ce pas et comme ça comme
ecoffey voilà tout à fait est ce que
vous êtes francs-maçons aveux de la
croix alors jeu par rapport à cette
question je dirai ceci c'est que la
démarche que j'ai effectués dans cette
recherche comme dans mon ouvrage
consacré aux illuminati ou un autre
livre que j'ai publié un essai
historique qui lui n'est pas une bande
dessinée qui s'intitule i clair à la
franc maçonnerie est en passe de devenir
un ouvrage de référence c'est que ce
sont avant tout des ouvrages
d'historiens donc en aucun cas des
ouvrages de militants en faveur ou en
défaveur de la maçonnerie la franc
maçonnerie dévoilé c'est donc signé
arnaud de la croix avec des dessins de
philippe bercovici essai paru tiens oui
c'est qu'il éditeurs déjà abbas et le
lombard
évidemment le lombard
[Musique]
damien vous vous sortez votre troisième
album vous l'avez intitulé satan et eve
que je trouve un excellent jeu de mots
je m'étonne que l'on est attendu si
longtemps pour le faire on écoute un
premier extrait la chanson s'appelle top
ipilule est fantastique je ne semble ni
corps physique chaque particule et
harmonie c'est comme si je n'avais
jamais vécu avant chaque coupon coucou
[Musique]
coc
coco
coucou
[Musique]
il s'agit d'une apologie de la drogue
les paroles sont parfois codé alors j'ai
des doutes non c'est pas une apologie la
rogue c'est une vision sur un certain
futur on top là c'est le morceau combien
de passes et 1
c'est une chanson qui parle du bien-être
sur demande donc l'évoquent une
prédiction du futurologue à ses célèbres
qui s'appellerait kurt weill et qui dit
en 2029
l'implant cérébrale permet l'immersion
dans une réalité virtuelle total et
multi sensorielle sans l'aide
d'accessoires externe est en fait les
unités les utilisateurs de cette
technologie se transporte à l'endroit de
leur choix en l'espace d'un instant
[Musique]
c'est à dire qu'ils ont ils ont cet
implant ils cliquent sur le truc là il
se retrouve ailleurs d'un coup quoi
oui on hamm est symbolique on a même
imaginé qu'on pourrait s'échanger nos
mémoires nous souvenir grâce à cet
implant s'il existe un jour oui
carrément
c'est un album particulièrement
futuriste satan et eve ont fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après pour en
parler avec damien
[Musique]
on nous sommes toujours avec damien dont
le troisième album satan et eve vient de
sortir
vous êtes le chéri de la critique un le
monde télérama les inrockuptibles vous
adore depuis votre premier album en 2006
je me demande d'ailleurs est ce que
c'est bon signe quand on a le monde
télérama et les inrockuptibles wassa des
parents il ya plein de façons de faire
enfin moi je te dire c'est la victoire
ouais non moi je suis un veut sans
prétention une exception cauvin c'est à
dire que j'en pas vraiment dans le moule
mais vont peut-être le disque est pas
mal donc ils vont quand même en parler
[Musique]
mais ouais ouais c'est bien mais disons
qu'on pourrait on pourrait se dire le
fait qu'ils en parlent pour être
rédhibitoire comme vous dites
et finalement je pense que c'est une
bonne chose avait fait trois albums en
quinze ans parce que vous avez tellement
pressé quand même la l2 votre premier
clip de cet album là il est sorti en
2010 8,1
ce que vous faites dans les deux
journées oui c'est vrai il ya un truc
avec le temps en fait suis enfin c'est
un mélange je pense d'une grande exil
exigent ans
et puis d'une précarité technique
c'est-à-dire de moyens limités
en gros j'ai des goûts de luxe mais peu
d'argent donc voilà c'est ce qui définit
[Musique]
toute ma musique
enfin tout ouïe la façon dont est
transmis et ma musique en janvier
l'ordinateur wen qui a dix ans qu'ils
peuvent tout le temps parce que les
plugins sont craquer les cloisons sont
ultra-fines il ya les travaux des
voisins l'aspirateur l'ascenseur pour le
faire les prises de voix
par exemple je suis dans une cabine de
son que j'ai fait monter qu' une cabine
de des ptt des années 50
donc c'est un truc c'est assez sale
isole bien du son mais c'est très étroit
donc quand on veut faire parler de prise
de guitare il faut se mettre en
diagonale enfin c'est très compliqué
tout ça prend du temps mais aussi il ya
un truc je pense que c'est un peu comme
les champagnes kong 1 parfois plusieurs
années en cave pour développer des
arômes des complexité aromatique
il ya ce côté traîner sur le temps pour
pour avoir trouvé une saveur
un peu inédite en fait elle a écouté
vous l'avez bien gardés au chaud
où est la température ambiante selon les
goûts puisque vous avez mis huit ans
entre le l'album précédent et celui ci
on va écouter un extrait de the bread
[Musique]
hop
le trans humains m haies
sans opposer le raf
ils marchent en ligne droite et
sur la photo qui sont dans le coma égal
double y assister
[Musique]
alors ça c'est aussi c'est assez codé il
ya même une double dégâts sion sans
opposer d'entravé qui veut dire que en
fait ça s'annule
donc ça veut dire qu'on est d'accord on
s'oppose pas est ce que ce serait bien
est ce que ce ne serait pas de la
propagande transhumanistes ce morceau je
précise que l'homme que l'on voit c'est
d'haydn auckland dont avec son bras
bionique
c'est un homme qui a eu un accident du
travail qui a été occulté et qui depuis
a se brassent on en voit dans votre clip
est ce que vous ne voyez pas vous même
le transhumanisme comme une société
secrète un peu comme les francs maçons
et est ce que vous n'avez pas envie d'y
adhérer
nan peyi tous n'ont par contre pas du
tout mais oui je suis d'accord et c'est
dans la lignée de ce qu'on vient de voir
avant et oui oui c'est sûr le times
transhumanisme donc l'être humain du
futur va augmenter sa vision sa mémoire
son intelligence et finir par ne faire
qu'un avec l'ordinateur mais moi en fait
je suis ni pour ni contre
c'est à dire je suis comme un narrateur
qui observe cet événement qui ni l'udc
table je pense mais de façon neutre et
objective
je suis dans l'acceptation sereine d'un
destin inéluctable
bon et puis il ya toujours de l'humour
chez vous on va le voir avec river side
ce sera le dernier extrait de cet album
et vanilla riverside
ça c'est pour faire danser les filles
danser toute la nuit au riverside mes
courses
[Musique]
danser toute la nuit au riverside mais
pousse trop dansé toute la nuit au
riverside mais gusto
dans cette plaine au riverside cousteau
damien l'humour ça fait pas c'est pas un
problème ça fait pas baisser la
crédibilité dans l'électro pop
aujourd'hui c'est à dire baisser la
devise est je sais pas par exemple chez
les rappeurs quand on venait de la
bourgeoisie la crédibilité besset voyez
il fallait venir de la rue et si
possible de la banlieue et des rues
chaudes l'humour ça pourrait être pareil
dans l'électro il n'était pas très
marrant dans l'électro au début ouais
non non c'est non je mange et ans a
montré ce que je vois comme je le vois
et puis c'est pas grave s'il ya une
perte de crédibilité ou une augmentation
de crédibilité enfin je suis
complètement désintéressé toutes ces
histoires de bien paraître en fait
l'album s'intitule satan et eve et il
est enfin paru
[Musique]
christian gay me c'est sous votre alias
c215 que vous êtes connu en tant que
street artist et cet essai votre art
celui du pochoir que vous expliquez dans
un manuel aux éditions eyrolles l'art du
pochoir
ça consiste à atteindre à travers un
masquage dit comme ça ça n'a pas l'air
très compliqué d'autant que l'on peut
utiliser le découpage de quelqu'un
d'autre
alors je vois que vous avez beaucoup de
bombes derrière vous d'abord est-ce que
je vais bien résumé est ce que l'art du
pochoir
c'est bien ça c'est l'art de peindre à
travers un masquage quel qu'il soit
et oui il est encore et toujours
question de masques puisque depuis
l'origine en fait les premières traces
de pochoirs qu'on connaisse dans les
grottes c'était une main qui d'ailleurs
est ce qu'elle figure dans votre livre
c'est là la fameuse main humaine delà de
la grotte chauvet
voilà ceux typiquement explique le new
role regardant c'est parfait en fait
l'individu qui était placée là amis des
pigments dans sa bouche
il a posé la main sur la paroi il a
craché les pigments je vous laisse
imaginer la dentition et en retirant
qu'est ce qu'on retire le masque le
dessin apparaît on peut dire en négatif
où en est vide et voilà on en voit
derrière vous d'ailleurs au fond là-bas
il ya un masquage bleus et puis on voit
toutes vos bombes de couleurs que vous
utilisez
pour pour faire votre travail on
découvre que dans votre livre que le
pochoir ça peut être monumental 1
aujourd'hui
en fait c'est un outil qui n'a
absolument aucune forme de limites c'est
ça qui est intéressant parce qu'on fait
évolué complètement empiriquement et
collectivement
sa pratique est aujourd'hui
effectivement on peut il ya des
techniques qui permettent de raids et de
créer des pochoirs de 20 à 30 mètres
on voit l'immeuble carrément elle c'est
celui d'auch b qui est là et c'était
très connu et dans moins d'un kg et dans
le xiiie arrondissement et qui a été
créée par shepard fairey aubay à
l'occasion en tout cas des attentats des
du bataclan en hommage à la france
cela pour le coup c'est carrément délai
de papier comme du papier peint qu'on
était collée sur le mur qui ont été
découpés et vidé à même le mur ou au
cutter et qui a été peint et ensuite on
a retiré la les papiers qui étaient
collés sur la paroi laissant apparaître
le dessin est alors comment vous faites
vous alors je vais vous pas là vous
comment vous faites pour le colorer ce
pochoir ça aussi vous nous l'expliquer
dans votre livre mais on a envie de
comprendre comment on passe de la gauche
à la droite
on imagine bien comment vous pouvez
découper le premier et puis ensuite
passer de là mais ce serait monochrome
sur le mur comment on fait pour arriver
à ça alors moins personnellement
frédéric j'utilise plusieurs pochoir
pour parvenir à chacun de mes dessins et
je conçois mes pochoirs à la manière
d'un dessinateur d'ailleurs je les
dessine au scalpel il n'y a pas de
logiciel derrière qui puisse créer cela
et je fais d'abord des pochoirs dos rond
et ensuite je fais des pochoirs de
lumière c'est le descendant les ombres
sur un glacis sur un glacis aux prêts
existants et ensuite je remonte en
lumière c'est de la peinture ni plus ni
moins et aujourd'hui on utilise
également le les techniques numériques
pour faire pour faire des dépôts choix
il ya le duo smic que vous interviewez
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens beaucoup
d'invités dans ce livre il ya tous les
grands noms
du pochoir qui sont là il ya ce duo de
bristol par exemple utiliser le
numérique alors de quelle manière on
peut utiliser il ya plusieurs logiciels
qui permettent d'interpréter des photos
préexistantes puisque maintenant on est
dans l'ère du numérique et qui
permettent de donner une lecture binaire
d'un visuel déterminé par cette fois un
logiciel mais on peut créer un dessin
dans l'illustrateur on peut user de
filtres dans photoshop et à partir de
découpe laser parvenir à des résultats
extrêmement optique j'ai voulu inviter
tout un tas d'artistes parce qu'en fait
mon moi j'ai plus d'un demi million de
personnes qui me suivent depuis une
quinzaine d'années sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'ai été harcelée toutes ces
années en disant mais comment tu fais et
je considère que déjà je suis un
autodidacte j'ai pas fait d'école dans
les apprentissages force et académique
donc j'ai pas fait d'école d'art et je
considérais que c'était trahir les gens
que de leur dire voilà je vais te donner
un livre de recettes donc j'ai tenté de
faire un livre ou j'analysais en théorie
l'outil est pour chacun des aspects de
cet outil et de son potentiel
je vais convoquer en fait des artistes
que j'ai rencontré dont je sais que cet
aspect de la technique est le point fort
sur lequel leur oeuvre repose
c'est à la fois un livre extrêmement
personnelle d'une synthèse qui ne
dédouane complètement ce qui fait que
j'ai jamais vraiment donné d'ateliers
j'en donnerai pas qui me permet de
laisser les gens en tout cas dans leur
curiosité et à la fois de montrer en
tout cas ce que cet outil peut avoir
dans ses particularités de plus
exceptionnel à travers d'autres artistes
qui l ont exploité complètement le
pochoir en tout cas c'est toute une
philosophie de la duplication
je m'étonne qu'il n'avait pas évoqué le
fait que le premier portrait qu'on a
trouvé dans l'est dans les rues peint au
pochoir c'était celui de sony dans les
rues de rome j'étais sûr que ces points
vous plairait en fait c'est un outil qui
est liée à la propagande et à la
duplication qui a prospéré en tout cas
dans l'âge moderne de ce fait on avait
vu albert gleizes et d'autres qui
avaient qui avait aussi insérer cette
technique dans leur peinture parce que
c'est vraiment l'outil de la modernité
et qui a évolué à mesure que des
innovations technologiques ont
accompagné cet outil
on est loin de l'homme préhistorique est
obligé de broyer des pigments dans sa
bouche et de l'est craché on a des
banques ont beaucoup évolué avec des
quantités de couleurs comme vous le voir
un extraordinaire différents différentes
textures de telle assise de transparence
des effets couvrant des des embouts qui
permet d'aller plus ou moins loin mais
on a aussi bien sûr toute la culture
qu'on a appelée ono les penalties de le
multimédia et la culture du numérique a
permis aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on en est
une banque d'image infinie qu'on ait des
outils de traitement de ces images qui
sont extraordinaires on a tous
finalement à la fois une imprimerie un
ordinateur etc
chez soi et on arrive à des résultats
tout à fait stupéfiant
je me dis en fait que je devrais moi
même lire cet ouvrage chaque matin parce
que parce que en fait j'ai essayé de
faire un inventaire tino qui ne retrace
pas seulement ma technique mais
l'ensemble des techniques dans ce
qu'elles sont merveilleusement c'était
c'est la question que je vais vous poser
moi je me souviens à paris les premiers
pochoirs qu'on a pu remarquer c'était ce
mystique dans les années 80 et vous y
fait évidemment allusion parce qu'elle a
joué un grand rôle un dans dans la
diffusion du moins dans la connaissance
qu'on a pu avoir du pochoir
voilà c'est ça qu'on voyait dans paris à
l'époque et je me demandais de votre
point de vue à vous est-ce que cet art a
beaucoup évolué depuis ces trente
dernières années
il évolue sans cesse et c'est bien pour
ça que je suis très heureux d'avoir
aussi présenter des artistes plus jeunes
que je ne le suis dans cet ouvrage parce
que ça continue d'avancer on apprends
moi même je j'apprends des choses de
manière empirique souvent parce qu'on se
plante tout cas quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas et qu'il faut résoudre un
problème qui était un qui était un as
prévu en quelque sorte c'est comme ça
qu'on apprend
et ça évolue sans cesse après on reste
aussi bien collectivement que chaque
artiste limitée finalement par le singe
que l'on est ici mythe avant tout soi
même c'est à dire qu un artiste le
problème c'est qu'on parle toujours de
copies ou d'imitations mais en fait
c'est davantage chacun de nous qui
s'immisce chaque matin dans son oeuvre
et qui tend à vouloir sans cesse se
reproduire la même technique est la même
esthétique on est aussi retenu par un
marketing ou la reconnaissance des
autres on peut pas
être complètement différent chaque matin
même si même si la schizophrénie
pourrait nous y aider non on doit ce
qu'on doit se maintenir une certaine
structure comme le pochoir nos cadres et
bien on doit essayer de conserver une
esthétique et de la faire évoluer c'est
aussi ça être un artiste
mais le nombre de rendu possible à
l'aide du pochoir est infinie le manuel
du pochoir c'est signé ces 215 essai
paru aux éditions eyrolles
on va parler maintenant de matisse lui
aussi s'est pas mal renouvelée au cours
de sa vie pour arriver au découpage
s'était pas encore les découpages comme
les vôtres mais vous allez voir c'est
quand même pas mal
[Musique]
elle est noire du jardin vous êtes
historienne de l'art et vous publié aux
éditions du chêne un livre sur le
peintre henri matisse dont on célèbre le
150e anniversaire de la naissance avec
une grande exposition au centre pompidou
c'est quoi pour vous le génie de matisse
donc tout à l'heure on parlait de cette
imitation de ceux de cette contrainte
parfois qu'on des artistes en effet à
rester conforme à un style qui leur est
personnel mais chez matisse on a quand
même un bel exemple de renouvellement
perpétuel parfois contraints par la
maladie avec ses gouaches découpées
mais on voit quand même une évolution
dès ses premières heures on a du
fauvisme on a un mari très décoratif qui
flirte avec l'orientalisme il a un peu
touché du bout des doigts le cubisme
sait on ne peut pas l'associer au
cubisme
officiellement donc oui à un
renouvellement et surtout hors mode
moi je trouve c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec mathis cécile s'est pas
conformé à ses mouvements artistiques de
l'art moderne du début du 20e siècle
il a toujours fait un style qui lui
tenait à coeur à lui style très
personnel
alors pour moi bâti c'est d'abord la
couleur est d'ailleurs quand on
feuillette de votre livre on est frappé
c'est cet amour de la couleur pure qui
va être la marque du fauvisme au départ
là on le voit c'est dans sa période un
peu pointis un tableau que j'aime
beaucoup luxe calme et volupté un
tableau qu'il a peints à saint tropez
son rapport à la couleur vous vous
l'expliquez comment fin du mois vous le
voyez comment plus exactement mais c'est
un outil narratif en fait la couleur
c'est plus ça sert plus à décrire ça
sert plus à aa est sûre ça ne sert qu à
ré a montré la réalité sûr que oui on a
une pomme verte à la peindre en vert
parce que c'est la réalité est que ces
descriptif là on est vraiment dans un
outil narratif la lumière pendant la
couleur associée à la lumière servent à
raconter quelque chose ça va appuyer
même l'histoire parfois nous montrer
peut-être des choses qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément palper au premier regard et
puis surtout il s'autorise une liberté
folle avec la couleur c'est à dire que
c'est une couleur qui n'est pas réaliste
mais qui pourtant touche à l'émotion
donc elle nous paraît pas content
comme incongru quand on la regarde cette
couleur même quand elle ne représente
pas une réalité pure et dure pourquoi se
détester t-il avec picasso à votre avis
ce que c'est pour moi les deux grands de
la peinture à ce moment là ils sont
comme face à face et pourtant ils
s'évitent constamment il ne faut surtout
pas rester dans la même pièce
on dirait les explications à une
explication peut-être pas j y étais pas
mais je ne crois pas que mathis tu
détestes picasso chance et surtout
picasso qui détestent houthis
puisqu'elle a fait souvent preuve
d'arrogance un ya même une citation dans
l' ouvrage ou ou picasso parle justement
du fait que mathis a beaucoup regardé
ses oeuvres ce qu'est ce qui est assez
arrogant mais mais je crois qu'en fait
c'est une des stations comme seuls les
gens qui s'admirent profondément peuvent
avoir en fait c'est dire qu'ils se
reconnaissent ils savent qu'ils tendent
un art qui est pas similaire mais qui
répondent même questionnement qui est
aussi issu des mêmes réflexions
il s'inspire de sézanne tous les deux
cézanne c'est un peu leur maître à tous
l'art africain aussi qui les intrigue
tous les deux et donc voilà il ya deux
compétitions mais qui n'en est pas
vraiment une
et encore une fois picasso appartient à
un mouvement très à la mode lui c'est le
cubisme c'est l'art moderne parisien
très parisianiste mathis l'huile et en
dehors de ces modes et ça aussi
peut-être créer cette distance entre les
entre les deux artistes
et là il avait été dans le fauvisme
quand même qui a eu son heure de gloire
et qui a fait scandale à son époque il a
le génie du décor métis et on le voit
bien dans la plupart des tableaux que
vous avez sélectionné
d'ailleurs vous avez fait un petit à
photographier abusant de pourvoir les
thèmes qui l'utilisé en fait ce qu'ils
utilisent le plus c'est les chaises mais
je trouve que la chaise intéressante
parce que elle symbolise l'absence parce
qu on a toujours premier au premier
abord on regarde toujours baptiste comme
étant très optimiste très exubérant
c'est de la couleur c'est joyeux c'est
plein c'est plein voilà c'est très
chatoyant mais il ya une forme de
mélancolie
on peut pas l'ignorer et elle est
souvent assez subtil et la chaise par
exemple vide
elle introduit une notion mélancolique
et clairement elle symbolise une
abstention est prégnante qui fait que
voilà on a une ouverture on se dit que
l'histoire ne faut pas la prendre au
premier degré ya peut-être quelque chose
d'un peu plus triste
derrière derrière ses couleurs et
derrière ces motifs très très en place
je sais quand je parle de décors sont à
la fois des surfaces des imprimés des
motifs qui sont là derrière les
personnages et parfois même devant
il a aussi là on le voit par exemple que
c'est pas un grand dessinateur de
matisse mais on voit qu'il a à la fois
le génie de la couleur le génie des
motifs le génie des surfaces oui déjà
c'est un grand collectionneur en fait de
tissus de textile et collectionne des
tissus et collectionne des costumes
folkloriques là on a une blouse romaine
typique dont qui joue un peu au
costumier océanographes quand ces
modèles arrivent à l'atelier il
farfouille dans les malles on entend des
tissus un peu partout des étoffes au mur
le modèle choisi d'aider robe ou enfin
il fait choisir plutôt des robes des
blouses des vêtements ou par ce même
motif donc oui c'est important parce que
entre encore une fois ça introduit la
couleur et s'introduit la ligne aussi
parce qu'il ya aussi ce jeu de la ligne
qui est très présent chez matisse alors
le voit c'est une année il y en a pas
tant que ça hein dénicher bâtisse oui
non c'est vrai que quand il y en a
quelques-uns prend on n'a pas mis tant
que ça dans l'ouvragé
il a quand même représenté venu mais il
représente la femme surtout qu'elles
soient nus ou habillés et il ya un
travail sur la perspective qui est
toujours aussi un peu
un peu enfin qui nous paraît anormal
quand on regarde un tableau de matisse
on voit le dessus et est très souvent il
fait ça avec les tables il faut sa
perspective pour qu'on voit ce qu'il ya
dessus toujours sont abordés surface oui
en fait ils nous donnent tous les angles
de vue ça qui nous facilite la tâche
on n'a pas besoin de s'imaginer quoi que
ce soit lui nous offre tout parfait sur
un plateau d'argent on a vu d'en haut vu
dans le seau à côté à gauche à droite on
voit tout et en même temps c'est une
contradiction aussi avec le fait qu'il
ait beaucoup dans la pl parfois il ya on
ne perçoit pas le font en fait chez
matisse ont l'impression tout et eau sur
le sur le même plan sur le même degré
donc oui il ya à la fois une
multiplicité d'angle et en même temps et
quelque chose d'assez plat et ça
rappelle certains tableaux de la fin du
moyen-âge d'ailleurs où on avait des
perspectives différentes d'aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit enfin on l'a dit au
début il va finir ça à la fin de sa vie
par faire des des papiers découpés ou
des gouaches découpées
tout ça parce qu'il a beaucoup de mal à
se déplacer à ce moment là se tenir
debout
ça va donner des choses magnifiques
d'ailleurs
là il s'est véritablement renouvelé j'ai
l'impression est ce qu'il est le seul à
avoir pratiquer cet art là comme il l'a
fait lui mais il a été le premier en
tout cas vraiment encore une fois c'est
pour des raisons de santé ni les coupes
il est au début il est handicapé là il
est gêné dans ses mouvements mais après
il va être complètement alité et c'est
aussi ce qui est intéressant dans ses
gouaches découpées c'est que ça ça
reflète aussi le travail en atelier qui
est en travail qui était tout à fait
acceptée au moyen âge à la renaissance
qui se renouvellent book ou encore
aujourd'hui avec l'art contemporain
parce qu'en fait mathis de son lit de
l'hôtel régina demandé à des assistants
de colorer de découper les gouaches pour
lui et lui après indiquer où il fallait
les places et donc c'est un travail
personnel et collectif à la fois votre
livre vient donc de paraître aux
éditions du chêne vous avez vu
l'exposition du centre pompidou non pas
encore mais j'ai hâte at il de tous les
plus beaux tableaux donc espérons merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]